well it's such a great honor to have the  first lady with us today for the  reopening of the Washington Monument and  we are joined here by some wonderful  fourth graders and the reality is the  monument has been closed for a little  over three years and today is the grand  opening we're joined by 4th graders  because we also have a program to get  the our fourth graders outdoors and so  the first lady will be visiting with the  kids going up to the monument tower and  then obviously interacting with them for  the great outdoors with some great  outdoor pass was and we'd encourage  every 4th grader in America to get  outdoors and spend some time on our  wonderful public lands and so with that  we'll go ahead and do a ribbon cutting  with some help from the 4th graders